if you have been diagnosed with type 1
or type 2 diabetes you can use an
insulin pump to control your blood
glucose level
an insulin pump is a battery powered
device used to deliver rapid acting
insulin to the body through a catheter
replacing the need for periodic
injections the parts of the device
include a battery-powered pump
a disposable reservoir of insulin
and a computer chip programmed to
deliver precise dosages
to help maintain a consistent glucose
level you can program the pump ahead of
time for continuous insulin delivery 24
hours a day an insulin pump can help you
adjust your blood sugar immediately
you can also program the pump to deliver
larger bolus doses of insulin right
before eating to accommodate or cover
the amount of carbohydrates you are
about to eat
once you have determined your glucose
level with a glucose meter you can
program your pump to send the correct
amount of insulin into your body
insulin travels from the pump through an
infusion set including a flexible tube
attached to a soft plastic cannula
inserted just under the skin
using an insulin pump may help you lead
a more flexible lifestyle while helping
you maintain a more consistently stable
glucose level studies show that regular
monitoring and maintenance of glucose
levels help prevent long-term diabetic
complications such as blindness kidney
disease heart disease and stroke
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you